high end high tech
and high price this is largely what the
public have come to expect
from electric cars a mustang is ford's
only current electric offering
but not for much longer it's promised
all european passenger cars will be
electric by 2030.
it's a maneuver of its business model to
meet ambitious government targets
the sale of new petrol and diesel cars
in the uk will be banned by 2030.
some say ford has been slow and
reactionary
i think we're right on time to the party
so we're
launching our first full electric uh
passenger car as we speak the
mustang mackie that you have with you
there and our first all-electric
commercial vehicle at the beginning
of next year we've put hybrids across
our
vehicle range and now it's the time to
go the the next step and that's
why we're going all in it raises
questions about ford's last remaining
plant in dagenham
how will it fit in as a maker of diesel
engines
are you able to commit to the protection
of the jobs though well we think we've
got a really strong
future in the uk i mean you can never
you can never say never but we have a
great workforce
very efficient facilities britain's long
been a leader in car manufacturing
but brands are moving on mass to consign
dirty engines to the classics
but at what cost jaguar land rover made
a similar pledge just this week
its new strategy means a loss of 2 000
jobs
ford's brand is synonymous with mass
motoring but ford are yet to produce
an electric car for the masses few
brands have
but now the whole industry needs to
pivot and pivot fast
the question is can britain remain a
leading car manufacturer
in fact electrification was one reason
honda gave for the closure of its plant
in swindon
and the uk hasn't invested in
gigafactories that make batteries
a planning application has been lodged
on the site of coventry airport
but it may not be enough there's this
huge race on now to build battery
capacity
the eu is well ahead on that the uk
needs to play catch up very quickly and
unless the uk starts making batteries on
a very big scale quickly
there's a real issue about whether the
uk car industry will actually survive
it may be a challenge too to persuade
consumers to make the switch
to believe electric is accessible helen
and smith sky news